[Music]
ahoy there reject nation is I John
Humphrey coming at you on Thanksgiving
Day here to check out the new aldo jones
joker weird trailer which i'm excited
for obviously we cover a lot of these
weird trailers here on the channel very
thankful for the man aldo jones happy to
see the progress he's made over his
youtube life and i just want to say a
quick thank you to all of you guys
anybody who's watching now anybody who's
watched a video on our channel before
anybody who has subscribed checked us
out on patreon subscribing to our
Stardust feed all that stuff really
helps out a lot anybody and everybody
who's taking a look at our channel or
any of our where's Karen at all really
appreciate that hugely and I mean it
supports us you know if this this is our
livelihood and it's not something
everybody gets to do so I'm really
thankful for that thank you guys for nur
ability accomplished yeah let's watch
this trailer with tons of experience on
the shoulders and software I introduced
is something that not feed the Yogi's
needs to start you need something more
to be a friendly something that gives
you the necessary tools to make new
edits but without using your mind with
some very complicated software we need
seems to be mastering order which is
free more aligned with fedora you can
easily do this pay attention to please
YouTube is full of with screen videos
and you can find and download them also
for my channel maybe you see make your
own video anyone you want to follow wrap
it on then put them on two different
tracks apply between screen - okay
the new screen is done okay I also use
the Alpha channel function to refine the
edges but see Laura gets the more than
this the software is supplied with a
huge
we pulled your titles transitions
effects and elements that you can use to
make a decent editor happy triangle with
you when you have found one you might
just drag and drop it on the video track
with filmora you also have access to
film stocks a library with hundreds of
effects you can download and use as you
wish for your creations it's about me
it's order matters a professional
opinion without any efforts so what are
you waiting for now no invention for
free I'm waiting for the honor for the
weird reorder and then I'll go download
these or more huh star we see more nice
all right everybody go go click that
link right now oh good I was not
expecting that
[Music]
[Music]
that's good that's your job that's
really good
[Music]
Quinn nice to meet you not your perfume
wait that the scent of death when I was
a little boy
[Music]
[Music]
setups patron
[Music]
always let me repeat all the Chandler
dance Oh Greg would love this oh good
not you at a whoa whoa
they have to size of socks Ebates
oh damn one small thing yes when you
bring me out can you introduce me as
joseline a water boy what can you
introduce me as Joe Nelson danger
[Music]
goodness golly jeepers this is
interesting I feel like every time I
watch Naldo Jones video now I'm kind of
peering into like a weird public access
of similar of like things yeah this this
is interesting
oh this is making me yeah I'm gonna go
check out that that trailer yes
oh damn ha ha oh good golly it's on
Blake Cox self-loathing interesting Taj
Jacobs
dargol on
Oh buddy well we made it in there do
love the aldohn
look at all these patrons gay guys
support all of this for Aldo Jones will
zicht Oh buddy that was a lot of fun I
like that the Joker in this honest
they're not honest trailer where am I
talking about weird trailer is like
constantly being shunned by the other
Joker's I mean that's just inserting a
Heath Ledger at the front I don't think
he's like actually trying to mock him
but even so it just sort of looks like
he's looking at Arthur like sticking his
tongue out at him and then later on
jelly don't you yeah I don't know I
thought that weirdly putting all these
different Gotham City characters these
different iterations of the Joker into
this I don't know it gave it an
interesting dimension yeah it's like
putting the other Joker on the TV no
one's laughing now I thought my jokes
man I just slagging off his jokes
Aquaman popping up at one moment and
it's funny because like the Aquaman
moment I thought was funny and goofy
especially just you know because he
thinks Arthur's cute at the same time
it's like the Harley moment actually
didn't seem as far-fetched to me like
when she's with him in the hospital
maybe not quite at that point in the
movie but especially full makeup oh my
god I can see them in the same universe
together not that I'm saying that needs
to happen I'm just saying like yeah it's
an interesting thing to note I always
appreciate when something cheeky and
funny and silly like this manages to
kind of shed a light that way of course
you got Tommy was Oh gotta get that
Tommy Joker in there but I think the
moment that got me the best was the
predator at the top which I knew it was
coming like I knew that there was
something coming and I did not expected
all the predator faces actually this is
pretty scary
pretty freaky in that moment especially
because like I expected basically
something akin to the kids reaction that
was a good reversal and you know the
Donkey Kong him choking Bart I thought
was fun but even better with the
Simpsons use was Jimbo and Kearney and
Nelson and them being the kids who beat
him up
like even in the movie I kind of thought
of them I feel like a lot of people
probably did it's a very ha ha kind of
moment I liked just the random Jim
Carrey is the key popping up through
this trailer dr. Robotnik and then you
have a spin turret dancing with him on
the steps and I appreciated the steps
you can see the way I guess how the
Jones kind of uses these trailers and
takes advantage of the moments and then
references other things kind of works a
man I mean obviously emo Peter fits
really well here but I thought the this
is Bardem moment it's funny I wondered
how manipulated that lip match was and
it doesn't look very manipulated and so
that cut from that into him kicking the
guy off the staircase pretty funny
pretty great and then you know the
reverse shot with Chandler like just
yeah this it turned the stairwell into
its own weird character in a totally
expanded way it's like the stairwell is
an iconic moment from the movie or is
becoming iconic pretty quickly so to
have it be like this endless thing where
he just keeps coming across people I
appreciated that that was pretty funny
yeah Christian Bale from The Machinist
you got another half a saucy Bates
Domino coming in and you know sticking
up for the other said it's like two
halves of the character or something
like that you know the bad luck version
and the good luck version this is like
up to the minute I love these you've got
the Tesla truck in here oh and the
moment was done with yondu I thought was
funny but the the title smashed just I
felt like that was the real kicker there
I like when a title smash can make me
laugh
and this did that as well as just
recently the Patrick H Williams how Star
Wars trailers weaponized nostalgia video
also did that so
Aldo Jones another great job good times
man always a pleasure always a pleasure
seeing the Aldo Jones what do you guys
think is this your favorite aldo jones
trailer yet what is your favorite aldo
jones trailer and what do you want to
see him take on next leave it in the box
as always you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell to get notified every time a review
or a video is out check us out on
patreon.com slash the real rejects we've
got tons of exclusive content Q&A is TV
show reaction stream alongs highlights
included for
some of those shows music video content
etc would love to have you over there as
well as on the Stardust app 30-second
reactions for any film TV show or
trailer lots of stuff we don't cover on
the channel as well so lots of places to
keep up with us and that's it for now
much love party people and thank you
again for all your support Happy
Thanksgiving
Cheers